from crust to sauce we're exploring the
best pizza in the big apple with our
very spicy
tour guide my children's aunt jill
kargman
all right i cannot wait to see what
you've done because i've seen photos of
the tour
i can't wait to watch this video check
it out with me
[Music]
first up is paulie g's in greenpoint
brooklyn
their pies have the best toppings this
place has been a new york institution
since 2010
with pizza patrons waiting in line for
hours to satisfy their carb cravings
paulie jeez is known for the best cheese
and the best toppings in new york can
you talk about what makes your menu so
special but we make sure that we're
using
the best versions of all those classics
yeah i was told when i was first
learning how to make pizza you don't
want any pepperonis kissing
because you get it into the oven lay it
flat let me back
pretty good wow
yes okay the magic moment
it is perfection
next up is ops pizza in brooklyn's
bushwick neighborhood
their pies have the best sauce we do
something really
simple and straightforward and
traditional which is just take
tomatoes out of a can that are really
really amazing
mill them together with a little bit of
salt and that's it we're gonna make a
marinara pizza today which is the
traditional
most like old school style pizza which
is just tomato sauce
oregano and garlic
want to use a little bit of garlic i
love those big cloves that will scare
off any vampire
oh yeah oh
yes oh there's a sizzle just like really
good chili flavor
yum it's so good
i know you think pizza has to have the
cheese pulp but this garlic and chili
oil and everything
is the same level of greatness delicious
next we're heading to emmy squared in
manhattan's upper east side
their detroit style pies have the best
crust
what makes a detroit style pizza it's
the crust that really makes detroit
style pizza most notable so we're going
to start with a low moisture
shredded mozzarella cheese and i'm
really going to emphasize
going around the perimeter of the pie
here before i
even worry about coming into the middle
so that that cheese is going to
really at the against the high heat of
the pan
will caramelize and create like this
fried cheese stick edge
and that will create that crispy frico
crust that we're that we're known for
it's crispy it's chewy it's delicious
impressed we trust what a better way to
wrap up our tasty tour
than with scott weiner scott is the
guinness world record title holder of
most pizza boxes in his collection i
heard that you brought a
very small portion of your collection
can i have a little tour of your
greatest hits
from tony's pizza in north beach in san
francisco designed by
ed hardy is that george clooney with a
net
i think it is that's the only george
clooney's face with like
a kerchief go to brazil they're not all
square
they're round this one's from india and
this is the breathable
pizza oh bent it the contact free
is the funniest it has the built-in
spatula yup and wait i brought one so i
didn't have to destroy the box look at
this thing
that is a riot this becomes your spatula
for your slices
[Music]
you